- Nous sommes à quelques
kilomètreslelelement
de la frontière américaine.
Dans ce quartier très pauvrehahe
de paix, qui tranche
avec les environs.
Dan
centaine d'élèves de 3 à 12 ans
apprennent de nouvelles choses
pour avoir une sorte de vie
normale. Tous ces enfants
centrale. Ils ont tous
à peu près la même histoire
à raconter, celle d'avoir quvuvr
et la violence n'étaient plus
supportables.
Comme Daniela, 11 ans,
quititititté le Honduras
avec sa mère. Elle est arrivée
ici il y a huit mois.aaaaaaaaaaa
Pour Lindsay Weissert, qui a
mis sur pied cette école appelée
endroit où les enfants peuvent
enfin se sentir en s
Depuis l'ouverture de l'école,
le nombre d'élèves a quadruplé.
par jour, et l'école pense
en ar r r r r prochainement 300.
Parmi ces enfants qui en ont
déjà tant vu, il y a
10 ans, qui a fui la violence
quotidienne du Salvador
Cela fait neuf mois
qu'il attend ici que leur
dossier d'immigration soit
par les États-Unis.
Mais avec la frontiè f f f f fe
depuis deux ans aux migrants
et des services d'immigration
qui tournent au ralenti,
impossible de sartrtrtrtrtrtrtr.
Alors, en attenda
son temps dans ce refuge,
situé juste à côté
Il n'est pas le seul à y vivre.
Entre 500 et t t t t t t t t t ,
entassées dans une promiscuité
extrême.
Justin nous emmène dans
ce qu'il appelle sa chambre.
lit, dans une chaleur étouffante
la jtetetetetetetetempératures
froides la nuit, c'est le lot
de beaucoup de familles ici.
Derrière chaque lit se cachentss
de migrants qui ont tout perdu
et qui espèrent toujo
Vanessa Esquivel, une Mexicaine
de Tijuana, qui donne un coup
de réfugiés et de demandeurs
s s s s s s s s fait visiter
l'endroit.
Sans trop de mocecececececececs
pour garder un semblant
de dignité.
Ici, ils font la file
afin de garder le contact avec
o o o o o o o o o ont quittés.
Là, on prépare la nourritureimi.
Quant à la lessive, ici,
on attend chacun son tour
pour laver ses vêtements
à la  r r r r r r r r r r r r r.
Le quotidien des migrants
se résume à attendre, attendre
et attendre encore que
r r r r r r r r r r r r r r r r.
qui essaient de s'adapter
à ces condition
Le fait d'aller à l'école
uiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiui permet de
se distraire, de penser à autre
chose et de relaxer, car Walter
aux enfants qu'ils côtoient a a.
parce qu'il a été menacéonononoé
qui a tiré.
Plusieurs mois aprarrivée à Tit
que son dossier de demande
d'immigration allait être
examiné, mais c'est à ce moment
leur frontière terrestre
aux migrants.
Une famille qui peut enfin
quitter le refuge et l
c'est une victoire
en demi-teinte ici.
Wututututututututututututute
sa vie, ne sait pas ce qui va
lui arriver, et ça le dévaste.
"Je suis vraiment passionné
par ce travail d'enseignant.dud"
Justin espère devenir plus tard
migrants.
Et il veut essayer de faire
traversé vers les États-Unis.
Face à l'inconnu, tous ici
fondent t t t t t t t t t t t ta
Maison-Blanche à rouvrir enfin
la frontière terrestre aux
migrants d'ici la fin du mois.
qu'ils seront acceptéspapapapapé